next book TV takes you to the 92nd
Street Y in New York City for a
conversation with primary colors author
and New Yorker writer Joe Klein he sat
down with political analyst Jeff
Greenfield to discuss his latest work
the natural the misunderstood presidency
of Bill Clinton in it mr. Klein attempts
to explain why and how things happen
during the Clinton administration
not just the scandals but also the
policy decisions that shaped both
domestic and foreign landscapes
it's an hour 25 minutes good evening and
thank you my name is Debra Nadel McGee I
am the director of the Charles Simon
Center for adult life and learning here
at the 92nd Street Y and I very much
would like to welcome you to America and
the world 2002 with three-time Emmy
Award winner Jeff Greenfield CNN
political commentator and host of the
nightly news and conversation show
Greenfield at large
jeff has reported on virtually every
major political campaign during his
career his analysis of contemporary
events and his quick wit has made him
one of the most trusted names in
television journalism tonight Jeff will
be in conversation with Joe Kline one of
our most brilliant political analysts
and a journalist whose access over the
years gave him a prime spot from which
to view every crucial event of the
Clinton presidency following their
discussion you will have the opportunity
to ask questions of our guests and if
you would just write your questions on
the cards that were handed to you as you
walked into the hall they will be
collected by our Usher's and brought out
onto the stage for the asking and at the
very end of the evening mr. Kline will
be signing copies of his latest book the
natural the misunderstood presidency of
Bill Clinton in the art gallery right
next door
following the program and now it is Bo
an honor and a pleasure to once again
welcome Jeff Greenfield to the 92nd
Street Y
they haven't started yet first let me
say that any of you trying to tune in
greenfield at large will be severely
disappointed because as some of you may
know the show has been canceled as they
say in spinal tap it wasn't that my
popularity was less it was just more
selective than the people at CNN would
have liked let me also be given more
seriously on a personal note this is the
first time in 20 years of this there's a
seat down there that has not been
occupied by the person who sat there
through all of these for 20 years and
that's my mom she passed away last fall
she was not only a devoted member of
this audience for understandable reasons
but she's also a devoted participant
here at the 92nd Street Y along with my
dad who also was here
religiously until he passed away about
five and a half years ago and more to
the point she was a passionate follower
of all things political and I know to an
absolute certainty that were it not for
her enthusiasm and love of politics it
would not have leached to me at an
indecently early age and my life would
have been different and the poorer for
it so as I did with my dad I'm
dedicating this series to hell in
Greenfield because it was one heck of a
woman
my favorite picture of any backstage
picture in the 20 years I've been doing
this is a picture of then Speaker Newt
Gingrich and my mother it was like the
Khrushchev Nixon kitchen debate and
Gingrich is like what is going on here
I'm convinced that's the real reason he
resigned the speakership now is there a
theme to these conversations I think
realistically we should think of these
three that I'm doing this spring is a
mosaic and they're really linked
together in an attempt to understand how
the city and the country and the world
has and hasn't changed six months after
the most shocking event of our time and
tonight we're going to hear from one of
the principal chroniclers of Bill
Clinton's presidency who can help put
the man in clear focus especially since
the world as it was when he left the
White House has changed so dramatically
then we're going to come closer to home
when we talk with the once and present
Police Commissioner Ray Kelly about
issues about safety and security and
terrorism that quite literally are
matters of life and death and last in
all the conversation about what to do
with that impoverished third of the
world from from whose ranks so much
enmity and anger stem we're gonna be
talking with George Soros this is a man
who spent the first half of his life
becoming one of the richest men in the
world and then is spending the second
half not only giving his money away but
literally nurturing hundreds of
different enterprises around the world
devoted to nothing less than the
remaking of the world into one that is
more peaceful more democratic less
impoverished and more decent so I think
these are gonna be pretty interesting
but we begin tonight with Joe Klein and
as I mentioned a moment ago with a
question of timing now some of you may
be saying to yourself what [ __ ]
scheduled this event on the night of the
Academy Awards well in the first place
most of you will be home in plenty of
time to catch the all-important
hour-and-a-half of awards that nobody
cares about best sound achievement best
costume best lighting and the
humanitarian awards to people who've
escaped indictment for their various
and second if you're worried about
missing Whoopi Goldberg's monologue here
it is there'll be two jokes about the
fact that Arthur Andersen is counting
the ballots there'll be three jokes
about all the african-american nominees
there'll be at least two jokes about
Russell Crowe's character and lots of
jokes about the people Whoopi wants to
sleep with and six jokes that George W
Bush is a [ __ ] done and speaking of
timing what genius scheduled this event
on the very day that the New York Times
Book Review carried a glowing front-page
review of a book called the natural
calling a deft funny adroitly written
the first savvy synthesis of the Clinton
age by none other than Joe Klein as some
of you know I suspect almost all of you
know mr. Klein tried to deal with the
remarkable character that was in his
Bill Clinton in his then anonymous novel
primary colors one of the best-selling
first novels ever ever ever and also one
of the smartest books about politics
ever his journey has taken him from
Boston's real paper to rolling stone to
New York magazine to Newsweek and now to
the New Yorker magazine we'll be talking
about some of what he has written and
I'm also delighted to call him a friend
of long studying so it is my great
pleasure to introduce to you the highly
unintel Auden
okay this book is subtitled the
misunderstood presidency of Bill Clinton
and as a TV journalist I want to begin
with the blindingly obvious what is it
that we misunderstand about this guy I
thought it was pretty well a done deal
huge gifts great political gifts
squandered them with everything his
personal flaws did did okay plummets the
Republicans could have done more what's
left well I think I would have called it
the in sufficiently understood
presidency of Bill Clinton but you can't
put that on a book jacket okay and I
think that the part that was
insufficiently understood
had to do with a lot of the things that
he did well let me give you one exam
1997 we get he yet the balanced budget
agreement with the Republicans everybody
knows that but very few people know that
in those negotiations he snuck through a
thirty billion dollar tax credit program
program for higher education hope
scholarships lifelong learning tax
credits ten million people a year take
advantage of that program they don't all
go to college a lot of them just taken
you know a night school course in
computers or accounting or whatever but
ten million people not chopped liver a
lot more than ever took advantage of the
GI Bill of Rights we never reported it
in 1997 why because we were reporting
the coffee's with the riad EES and the
rental of the Lincoln Bedroom and that
sort of thing it was it I mean that was
a scandal let and and worthy of
reporting but a lot of the things that
Clinton did and the and also the fact
that he came to Washington with a very
coherent philosophy especially on
domestic policy was overlooked
misunderstood insufficiently understood
so and a lot of in a lot of your book
you point out these what people would
call wonkish policy details that if you
take the whole picture
make him look like somebody who actually
did accomplish a lot on the social front
in fact you call his presidency serious
responsible and disciplined on the day
on the domestic policy so I understand
we're not gonna buts we're gonna stay
for a second but the reason I mentioned
that is when you think of Bill Clinton
the words responsible and disciplined
are not the first two things that pop in
you and the question is is it your
argument that the man's personal life
and the way he conducted his presidency
were just not the same I think that
that's largely true you know I did
before Clint and I had this campaign
going and as a columnist which was that
I would always support the the quarry
rather than the PAC and when when we had
one of these witch hunts going on on the
grounds that I'm Pro peccadillo you know
I think people with an interesting
sexual history and private life are more
likely to be better leaders because they
understand us better they understand
human nature better and just think about
it the track record in the 20th century
it's a leading indicator of success in
the presidency having having extremely
high IQ and not a very interesting
personal life as a leading indicator of
failure in the presidency which is why
Clinton was very interesting from the
start he had both a high IQ and an
interesting personal life so the tea
leaves were always mixed alright this
lead this opens a door I'm somewhat
reluctant to walk through because it
does suggest that it suggests that we
should be picking our presidents from
the ranks of you know rock Mick Jagger
if he were an American citizen you know
we should be picking our presidents from
the ranks of human beings rather than
rather than goody-goodies rather than
the people that you and I used to throw
spitballs at from the back row docked in
high school we don't want nerds in the
Presidency so you know you want to have
someone you'd want to have over for
dinner someone who would be interesting
I mean Dick Gephardt know
you know I'm gonna leap ahead and so
these here's where I'm going here Joe of
the Democrats running for 2004 who has
the most interesting peccadillo like
life that we might be able to make some
news here this is being telecast by
c-span I mean so who would you have
liked to have over for dinner basically
your standard being promiscuity as the
first first rank not promiscuity but
having lived an interesting life I mean
you know already I began to feel a lot
better about Al Gore who has not been
promiscuous when I learned that he
smoked a lot of dope in college up until
then I thought he was animatronic so any
of it I mean we so over emphasized these
human failings of politicians over the
last 20 years that we have driven a lot
of interesting people out of the
business and I think that that is a bad
thing this is actually what I wanted to
get get to because one of the things
that strikes me in your book and then
I'm gonna come back and point out how
you might have us I wouldn't call it
necessarily a contradictory argument but
you do take another tack later on all
through the 70s and 80s after Nixon
after Johnson and Nixon the press was
focused on presidential character the
famous book presidential character by
Dave barber which we translated stupidly
meaning what's your sex life like right
but even putting that mistake aside is
part of your argument that you could
have a deeply flawed character and and
still be an effective and and worthy
president absolutely I would say I I
think I've done this here before my idea
of the great president as a guy who
cheated on his wife drank a pitcher of
martinis every night played poker with
the staff cheated their lied to the
American people on basic issues of war
and peace SiC the IRS on his enemies and
my grandfather voted for him four times
franklin roosevelt let me also say this
about character
let me also say this about character
since we do in our idiotic way tend to
define political character merely as
whether or not you've you've had sex in
all the right places let me let me add
another thing to it my definition of one
of my definitions of political character
in fact one of my bright-line test for
politicians is whether they have the
courage to tell their strongest
supporters and the rest of us as well
something they don't want to hear now
Bill Clinton passes that test with
flying colors
he passes it as soon as he comes into
office in 1990 93 now Republican comes
to office the current Republican for
example and the first thing they do is
propose a huge tax cut Democrat comes to
office and the first thing that they do
is propose huge new social programs
Clinton comes to office the first thing
he does is propose a tax increase in the
service of deficit reduction that's an
abstraction and it was only a theory at
that point that if you reduce the
deficit Wall Street would respond
interest rates would come down and the
economy would would surge now that's a
three cushion Bagshot by any by any
measure but he went that way in a real
act of courage and it worked
free trade his party was opposed to free
trade but he would go to union halls in
1992 to explain his the fact that he was
supporting the North American Free Trade
Agreement welfare reform I went to black
churches with him throughout 92 and also
throughout his presidency where he did
not condescend where he talked about the
problems of crime single-parent fare
single-parent families and in the
disasters of that and also of the need
for welfare reform I could go on and on
and on and I'm not gonna but those were
very courageous things that he did and
yet there arrived and yeah no no the end
yet does a life graham the end yet does
not come from me it comes from you in
the book because you make this point and
yet
throughout this book you say I think if
I'm reading this correctly that there
were some of the character flaws of Bill
Clinton actually wound up making him a
poor president for him that is the need
to be loved by everybody you see you you
mention that he told people things he
didn't want to hear but there was
another side to him where it was very
hard for him to bring bad news to people
where where he did want one he could
never do it he could never did never
bring bad news to people one on one mean
he had this tremendous need for flattery
but all of that is also true I mean I
would argue that the Lewinsky scandal
had huge huge public policy consequences
and also public safety consequences but
you know life's pretty complicated and
that's what makes this a very
interesting and confounding guy I used
the word confounding in the book as well
there were tremendous strains there are
tremendous weaknesses and if you're
going to do a fair job of reporting
about him you got to do both now James
Carville said to me when the book came
out and people started describing me as
an apologist because I said some nice
things about him he said in his
inimitable fashion Kline all you have to
do is write one nice sentence about Bill
Clinton and you're an apologist that is
a comment on how ridiculous
public discourse has become in this
country especially in the 90s especially
in Washington where you have to come
from the left or come from the right and
you know as they do in crossfire I come
from the flaming middle and I am a
complexity junkie as I know you are as
well so in in service of that complexity
if you tell us that Bill Clinton has was
given insufficient credit for a serious
disciplined presidency that really did
accomplish a lot not just to college for
10 million people but the Earned Income
Tax Credit which put more money in the
pockets of the working poor then on a
without turning to the to the more juicy
stuff what would you say in the public
policy sense more that was was his where
his biggest failure Tate
because whatever okay you could do a
domestic and I'll do a foreign policy
one but there's a bigger foreign policy
one that that's involved in his personal
failings domestically giving over health
insurance reform to his wife who chose
the wrong path putting this on the backs
of employers was never going to work
there was a way that was going to work
and it was proposed by Bill Bradley in
the last presidential campaign which was
tax credits ironically enough the very
same path he took on the Earned Income
Tax Credit and the college scholarships
that was a big failing on the foreign
policy side he'll are more serious okay
I want to stop you here cuz I want to
turn it for him later if that's okay
we'll come back to okay promise because
because it raises one of the questions
about the Clinton presidency that baffle
people from the beginning and I guess
baffled you or maybe you've figured out
you mentioned the name Hillary Clinton
our junior senator let me just put it
the what up with her that is there is so
many people trying to figure out what
she was in the White House so let's
first start simply how much power did
Hillary Rodham Clinton have in the
Clinton presidency lots and lots
in what sense what kind of power well
she was the super-ego if he was the edge
she was the super-ego but also she he
truly respected her as a domestic policy
fellow pointment did she vet the cabinet
some of them yeah I once asked her if
there was a glass ceiling in the White
House this was very very early on and
she said no absolutely not I said then
why is it so important to have a woman
Attorney General they had already been
through to and and they came up with the
memorable gothic Janet Reno
who is now riding across Florida she's
running for governor and may well be
them even what up with her well she may
well be the Democratic nominee and she's
got every Democratic official in Florida
Terry and his or her collective hair out
at that mister isn't Democrat in Florida
in a professional that thinks she can
win which may be the best argument that
she might have a chance but there is a
second question about Hillary and I
don't know whether or not I mean I know
you addressed it in the book but there
was this widespread assumption even
among not just among the vast right-wing
conspiracy here that there was this deal
you know okay bill you go have your fun
but I get real power
if I leave you you're toast I will stay
with you but that means that I I've got
a I've got a lot of clout I'm the
co-president that you once sort of
described how how much do you buy the
quid pro quo theory I buy all the
theories know what complexity
yeah when one of the one of the great
yet ish formulations insidious one is so
now you're an expert on and the press
you know it was amazing to me throughout
the 90s it was so now you're an expert
on other people's marriages I mean most
people I don't know anything about their
marriage and so I chose to be
indiscriminately credulous to believe
everything I believe that he messes
around I believe that they fight like
harpies I believe that they have a cold
political partnership I believe that
they're best friends and I believe that
they love each other madly in every
sense of the word and people have been
involved in marriages know that that's
not so far-fetched and the and and the
the the best argument is why are they
still married I mean you know at this
point that deal if it existed you know
the statute of limitations has run out
she would her ratings would go through
the roof if if she dumped him and I
could tell you that during the past year
the two of them have spent two extended
vacations one in the Dominican
public one in Acapulco just the two of
them now sounds like a marriage to me
I can stand B stand to be corrected but
you know the the notion that people
would make all of these wild claims
about the inside of their marriage I
think is outrageous those are the kind
of things you do in fiction just a
couple of more things on this it strikes
me that that when you hear people say if
only Clinton had if only we could have
had the good Clinton without all the
mess he could have accomplished and you
know much more and then I think about
well what would what would Clinton look
like without the scandals that smart
that politically adroit that attempting
to redefine his party but a completely
honorable and upright guy and the answer
is Tony Blair the Prime Minister of
Britain and the question is so how much
more has Tony Blair been able to
accomplish absolutely unburdened by any
personal baggage than Clinton
accomplished some much of the same sort
of stuff by the way Earned Income Tax
Credit both of them were great for the
working poor but I mean greatness in
politics isn't something you do on your
own it's something that's thrust upon
you and you know by crises in the
outside world as for the Bill Clinton
with strengths and no weaknesses I'll
tell you a quick story when I was doing
the interviews for this book after one
of them mrs. Clinton walked in and the
three of us are having a diet coke and
Clinton asks me so why did you write
that book anyway
meaning primary colors and I said I
thought I saw it as a tribute to
larger-than-life politicians at which
point mrs. Clinton snorted derisively
and I said no no would you rather have a
larger-than-life president or a smaller
than life president and she shrugged in
agreement and I said and larger than
life
politicians have larger than life
strengths and larger than life
weaknesses she looked at me and she
looked at her husband and she said
that's for sure
which leads me to this last semi psycho
logical question davidmeredith in his
book first in the class very good I
think account of the early Clinton
terrific book said early and often you
can't separate them the same things that
made Clinton as you call him the natural
one of the great political figures of
our time also made him this person who
seemed to spend a fair amount of time
trying to destroy himself and betray and
disappointing friends and letting people
down do you buy that that the two are
absolutely absolutely and and at the
heart of it is the need to please to
figure out some way to get them to like
you he was always a creature of his
audience I once said to him you know I
could always tell when you were gonna
screw up and he gave me this look and he
said how and I said well when you were
thinking about the folks out there you
were usually pretty good because you
could really understand what they needed
and what they wanted but when the
audience shifted to the person who was
directly in front of you as it shifted
to the congressional Democratic
leadership during the first two years of
his presidency he lost track of the
country and just needed to please the
person right in front of him or needed
to or succumb to flattery from them like
Beth deserts what was at 86 times she
was allowed into the White House during
the last two years this is the wealthy
woman who helped persuade him to pardon
mark rich that's right and who raised
the gazillion dollars for the Democratic
Party and for the library and flattered
him ceaselessly this man because of his
neediness because of his desire to
please was incredibly susceptible to
flattery from all the wrong places
which leads to this wonderful quote you
got from Lloyd Benson who was Clinton's
first Treasury Secretary there were two
great quotes of Lloyd Bentsen he once
talking about the endless conversations
that went on at the White House he
described Clinton as the meatiness the
meatiest person I ever met
you know he he just he always wanted to
have meeting
and the meetings would go on for so long
that you would wonder if there was a
hostage situation but the other one the
more serious one was when you asked
Boyd Benson what was the difference
between the John Kennedy White House
composed of people who had all of whom
had fought in World War two many of whom
had seen combat and the Clinton White
House where nobody had gone near a
military installation and Ben and Benson
who himself was a combat veteran said
the difference between the Kennedy and
the Clinton White House was I guess we
didn't feel we had as much to prove
hello his brilliant quote which Taylor
seems to me to go back to a point that
at one point you and I had conversation
on I remember that it would one of the
things that might be neat to have in a
president and one of things that may
have made Ronald Reagan as strong as he
was was it he had had another life he
didn't go into politics to be loved he'd
already been loved in the movies bill
bradley whatever his weaknesses as a
campaigner seemed to have that he knew
what it meant to be cheered in his youth
and he didn't need politics for that
bill clinton needed politics to be low
no and and and with clinton and also
tony blair by the way and a great many
other of the baby boom generation
politicians al gore Dan Quayle you
remember Dan Quayle we haven't been a
very distinguished lot but they didn't
have a life before politics they're they
are essentially dilettante hsihu just
spent their whole lives seeking office
or as in the case of Trent Lott and and
george w bush being cheerleaders
standing on the sidelines literally
cheerleaders literally standing on the
sidelines and cheering not being in the
arena as Teddy Roosevelt said and as I
spent the 90s the 80s and 90s in
Washington I realized that there was a
huge gulf between our parents generation
and our generation and it had to do with
the fact that our parents had served and
sacrificed the greatest golf was between
Bob Michael who is the Republican
minority leader in the house
who was then succeeded by Newt Gingrich
Michael was a world war two veteran
Purple Heart seriously wounded at the at
the Battle of the Bulge and Newt read
fourteen books about the Peninsula
Campaign and Newt actually said at one
point that politics was war without
blood and that infuriated Bob Michael
because he knew the politics was the
exact opposite of war it's what you do
to prevent Wars and the kind of tactical
you know hyperbolic dilettantism that
Gingrich was ground zero of really has
characterized the politics of our
generation and so I would say that the
one thing that I'd like to see happen
during my remaining years in covering
this is to figure out a way to give our
kids the experience of service and
sacrifice without war which is why
Clinton's AmeriCorps program and other
national service programs like that I
think have been so well received and are
so important let me now turn to what you
had begun to answer before I stopped you
which was Clinton's greatest foreign
policy failure because it turns us to I
think to where we're going for the rest
of this conversation what was his
greatest foreign policy failure well it
was a it was a dual failure one was that
and relates to what I was just saying he
was as uncertain handling the military
as he was certain handling the economy
he never never had any confidence and
only intermittent interest in doing it
and that was partially I suspect as a
result of his own lack of experience in
Vietnam which is the kindest way that I
could put it and especially since I
agree with his position on the Vietnam
War so I think that that was a problem
throughout and then it was compounded by
the Lewinsky scandal which occurred a
couple of years after Osama bin Laden
began to show up on the radar screen
and as bin Laden became more of a
problem there were people in the
administration most particularly sandy
burger the National Security Adviser in
the second term but also a lot of
Clinton's national security and foreign
policy team who began to look at the FBI
and and and think what on earth is going
on there what a disaster they were at
war with Louis Freeh the FBI director
for several years for the for at least
the last four years of the presidency
Berger wanted to fire me I'm pretty sure
Clinton did too but they could not
because of Monica Lewinsky because it
would seem like another Saturday night
Massacre and I think that if the culture
of the FBI had changed started to change
five years earlier I mean you know say
what you will about John Ashcroft he is
doing the right thing now getting
getting the FBI out of legalistic build
case you know mode and in to try and
prevent these guys try and stop them
when they go to the flight schools and
before they drive the airplanes into the
buildings mode I think that would have
happened far sooner had it not been for
the Lewinsky scandal I cannot help but
mention that it's a question I actually
asked mrs. Clinton on by then show about
whether or not in retrospect that
example demonstrates that what a lot of
Clinton's defenders talked about is
private conduct it was nobody's business
when you're the president the private
conduct sometimes has even even if you
want to blame it on the people pursuing
you by giving them that sword it has
tremendous public policy implications
but be that as it may the broader
question this raises is you're working
on this book you've thought about
Clinton hung around with them in some
ways will always be identified with him
because the primary colors one way or
the other and then September 11th
happens and we begin to hear about the
failure of intelligence and the failure
to to understand what was out there
did it did the events of September 11th
cause you force you to reassess your
measure of Bill Clinton as a president
oh absolutely and what did you conclude
from it he became less you know less of
less successful because not only the
Louis Freeh example but there was
example after example after example
during those years when Clinton could
have acted could have over overrode
members of his administration for
example the Treasury Department burger
and a lot of the national security folks
went to the Treasury Department and said
let's start freezing assets or do using
cyber warfare against the banking assets
of the terrorists and the Treasury
Department said oh no no no you can't do
that because that would screw up the
international banking system and which
was a legitimate point the president you
know and and Clinton at that point goes
into self-pity mode well I couldn't do
it because the Treasury said this and I
couldn't do this military actually I
could only do pinprick you know a tax on
knows how imma bin Laden because the
military said that and he was the
president for god sakes
but that you know that to your point
about he couldn't he'd never felt
confident dealing with them right and
and I think that we have to we have to
remember though that not even the
Republicans no one was calling for a war
against terrorism before September 11th
there wasn't any public groundswell for
it but if the problem existed and he saw
it and this is a guy who really saw the
future pretty clearly I think if he saw
it and he had the skills to lead us he
had the moral responsibility to lead us
and he didn't do it on a more specific
on a more specific point one of the
areas that has come under very heavy
scrutiny ever since September 11th was
the relationship between the United
States and Saudi Arabia the fact that 15
of the hijackers were from there the
fact that there seems to be some
evidence that Saudi wealth goes to
support terrorism as long as it's not
within their borders and the fact that
the Saudi totally controlled press
routinely publishes blood libels as they
did just about a week ago the recipe for
how Jews killed Christians during
Passover and used their blood to make
matzah
I guess it may be hindsight but did our
focus on the Middle East peace process
Clinton desperately trying to get Barack
America to make a deal in the waning
months of his administration in some way
take such center stage that it it took
our focus off a burgeoning problem that
should have been paid more attention to
namely particularly the Saudi regime and
its relationship with terrorism is that
a fair rap or not well I think that the
Saudi problem I mean it wasn't Clinton
who played tennis with Prince Bondar was
George HW Bush so this is something that
it's existed for a long time but I do
and I'm gonna say something now then
that I guess it's kind of risky and it
might sound cynical but as someone who's
been to Israel a lot reporting Wars in
elections for 20 years I think that the
best-case scenario there was what we had
between 1993 and the summer of 2000
which was the appearance if not always
the reality of a peace process I think
that Clinton in the service of his
legacy pushed far too hard far too fast
he misread Arafat there was no way that
that deal was ever going to get done it
would have you know it would have called
Arafat would have to change his
definition of who he is as a person to
do that I mean you know he Clinton said
to me that at one point he said to him
you know us Yassir if this goes through
you're gonna have to get a desk meaning
you're gonna have to sit behind a desk
and you're gonna have to you know make
decisions about this and that rather
than fly around the world and be the
darling of the European left and the
Saudis and I said too you know and I
thought well if you knew that much about
Arafat
what made you ever think you'd want to
sit behind a desk and I think that as a
result we've had this terrible terrible
explosion I think it might have come in
any case
but if you'd given the process a lot
more time in the people there a lot more
time and new generations time to get it
to grow up and accept the reality of a
Jewish state there you might have
eventually gotten a piece to 2010-2020
whatever what you've got now is a very
very frightening situation one of which
elements a fright appeared on the front
page of the New York Times today you may
have skipped it on your way to the book
review but no actually that was that was
the one thing that I pored over okay
there's this front page story in today's
times that I ran you visited some months
ago did a lengthy piece of The New
Yorker has been upping the ante with the
Palestinians in effect not just
providing weapons providing money
encouraging the Palestinians with
Arafat's apparent cooperation approval
understanding to wage to escalate
violence against Israel if that first of
all based on what you found in Iran do
you by that I mean this I realize this
is a Hall of Mirrors everybody talks to
different people is there anything to
that and if so what does it tell us
about what the US should be doing with
Iran I mean on the one you have the
description of the axis of evil on the
other hand you have people say no we
should encourage those democratic
elements let's let's help the Reformers
reform maybe we can maybe they can be
less hostile to us with more complexity
more complexity well it's well look you
know I think that there was one
important fact that was missing in that
time story today the big new development
that they had was that at one point I
think was last May members of the
Palestinian Authority met with array of
Iranian officials they told us who the
Palestinians were they did not tell us
who the Iranians were and in that is
very very important because because if
the Iranians that the Palestinians met
with were
was nothing new if you know they're the
hardliners the hardliners are really
hardliners and the only way that they
can stay in power in a country where 70%
of the people are under the age of 30
and think that they're ridiculous is to
paint us as the Great Satan and and and
convince people that that we are but
what if the people the Palestinians met
with in Moscow were reformers what if
they were representatives of president
economies foreign ministry that raises a
whole huge policy question because then
you can't put any faith in reform at all
and so I would have really liked to have
known that one thing another thing that
wasn't in the story but people who were
in American security tell me when I
asked about the Corinne a the Korean a
left port the day on a day that I went
to the Friday prayers at Tehran
University
it's that was that ship filled with
weapons down for the Palestinians that
were seized by Israel between that
island and wherever they were going yeah
it was it was the day that I went to my
first American flag burning in Iran it
was a ridiculously perfunctory occasion
that took place in front of a movie
theater showing the Green Mile
but yeah you know I've often said
Iranian flag burning just ain't what
they used to be yeah in fact they may
never have been because that's very true
even in the hostage situation there
often were 50 people surrounded by 200
television cameras but interesting thing
about that ship the Korean a which was
filled with arms as you said headed
toward the Palestinian and Palestinian
Authority first of all Iran has been
shipping arms to Hezbollah Hamas and
other groups for as long as those groups
have existed like they helped form those
groups but they've come overland by
plane to Damascus and then by truck from
there there's a reason for that because
every ship in the Persian Gulf is
closely monitored everybody knows what's
on every ship and so there's some
curiosity in the American intelligence
community
as to why they put all these arms at
that particular moment on that
particular boat it may have been an act
of desperation by the hardliners sending
three simultaneous messages you know
first of all if the if the arms had
somehow gotten through that would be
great but even if they didn't they win a
huge propaganda victory in the Islamic
street where radicals man you know you
may be hearing about all this reform in
our country but forget about it we're
radicals but far more important was the
message that was sent to us because at
that point though you know there was
some fantasy that we were going to have
an alliance with Iran because we were on
the same side in post number 11 yeah in
Afghanistan and it was also sending a
message to President Khatami who the
ineffectual Iranian reform president
that's right who may even be in a state
of depression at this point because his
his you know he this guy gets larger
majorities than any other president
democratically elected president in the
world and yet he can't implement them
and his best friends are being arrested
and sometimes shot but it was a message
from the hardliners too hot to me saying
don't you mess around with those
Americans just a couple more things
before we turn to the audience questions
I assume you've all been scribbling
mightily on the cards I have heard more
than a few reasonably loyal Democratic
liberal types look around make sure that
nobody else was listening and saying you
know a much happier these guys are in
charge now than our guys now this is an
interesting thing well not totally these
are people who you know they they vote
Democratic they don't they they still
don't eat grapes very loyal liberal
types but I've heard this more than on
saying you know these guys you know
Rumsfeld and Cheney and Powell they're
tough they know how to fight I don't
know if our guys would have fought that
hard what do you what do you think about
that notion I have mixed feelings about
that on the one hand basic law of
American just bring the michael yeah is
that Democrats do better in domestic
policy Republicans do better in foreign
policy
I mean Democrats have really been pretty
lousy at wars ever since Roosevelt who
did very well with is is but Vietnam etc
Republicans are lousy with the economy
which is kind of amazing I think it's
because they mistake people like those
Enron folks as paid for patriotic
Americans and Democrats are never under
that kind of illusion no they invest in
Global Crossing right but in terms of
policy terms and in this case and and
over time all of the hard line stuff
that I said mmm I wonder if that's right
it was always right you know putting the
Pershing missiles in Europe when Reagan
did that right even Gulf War right in
fact they should have gone farther as we
now know you know when it and it's
really and and it's really interesting
the Europeans always want us to be very
aggressive until we're actually
aggressive and they then they start
saying you're bombing people wonder what
do they want us to do you know kill them
with Michael Jackson CDs I mean it's not
gonna happen
so I think that the way that Afghanistan
has been prosecuted has been the right
way although in some cases they came to
it rather late I do think that we should
act subtly to see what we could do about
the Iraq certainly and perhaps even Iran
I don't believe that we should do wild
macho things like calling three
completely disparate countries an axis
of evil especially two countries North
Korea and Iran where nobody knows what's
going on in those places
and I think that the the kind of
gratuitous unilateralism that we've seen
from the Bushies you know condi rice
going into a meeting of European
ministers and saying by the way we're at
a kyoto and having an Assistant
Secretary of State come to the UN and
lecture the rest of the world about the
right to bear arms in defense of a of
America's obsession to a small-arms
banned protocol those are not good
things I guess I'm thinking of a much
broader notion because I've seen this
talked about at some length and it often
it's often put in the context of
supposed gore had been president suppose
this happened on Clinton's watch when
George Bush used I wouldn't have done as
well well that made that may just cut to
the chase right there so let me amend
the question when George Bush uses a
phrase for instance like evildoers you
can't imagine Clinton or Gore using that
particular that particular phrase nor
might've okay Clinton less so but but
Gore I mean always was very clear minded
I'm very you know an Bosnia he wanted to
go write a no question about that but
the clarity I mean what some people
would call the simplicity of a phrase
like that I remember look when I
remember when Reagan used the phrase
evil empire about the Soviet Union and
it was much clucking of tongues and I
said to somebody said which part of that
don't you agree with right you know well
also when I first went to Russia in the
mid in the mid 80s I remember going to
the Bolshoi and with my Soviet minder
who wanted to show me what a good guy he
was and he goes like this and he says
Ronald Reagan evil empire
they loved it they loved it but you know
when one other thing that I would point
out though is that I don't think
substantively I'm not sure a substance
of League or would have been that much
different from Bush on this I'm not
quite certain about Clinton because of
his problems with the military however
one thing you can definitely say and
that is this the Republicans would have
never given Al Gore three weeks before
he mounted his you know his assault on
Afghanistan
within 24 hours Tom DeLay and the rest
of these geniuses would have been out
there saying saying what is this
namby-pamby stuff Gore when are you
gonna hit him no I think that's I think
that goes all the way back to the 2000
elections and then also that is really
important about you know Clinton's era
and Washington and 90s Bob Dole once
said to me that there is a wing of the
Republican Party that never accepted
Bill Clinton's legitimacy and you know
he actually won I mean you know it
wasn't like 2000 it was you know it was
these were two clear-cut victories and
it and you know being opposed
intellectually is not only a right but a
responsibility to the opposition but
being as flagrantly viciously militantly
constantly opposed as those Republicans
were to Bill Clinton to me smacks of a
lack of patriotism it it says that they
have an insufficient understanding of
what democracy is all about here's the
last thing I want to turn to it's a nice
specific question and I'm asking it
because I have notions about it but I
don't have the right to just spout so I
have to hear your answers first and then
I can respond I just want to lay the
tarts on the table here after September
11th will change everything so many of
us said ranging from no more irony and
diversion and entertainment in our
trivial news media to
not in our conversations a whole change
or a whole change in the country so let
me just put it this way what's changed
what hasn't well since you're so eager
to talk about it let me ask you let me
say I don't know Jeff what do you think
now you don't get away with it that
easily
what I'm let me for instance has it made
do you think it has made the country pay
more attention to the Civic business
that was in such you describe it very
well in your book how you know that this
years of affluence and ease and peace
and basically basically turned politics
into a parlor game is the country
treating it more seriously now
intermittently I don't think that it you
know not nearly as much changed as we as
we thought at that time I mean the event
was so horrific and followed close on by
the anthrax that it did really seem a
war I don't know that it's a war I think
it's a campaign and it is by its nature
intermittent and it plays on our natural
tendency as Americans to kind of drift
back into our soft affluent suburban
narcolepsy and I think that there is you
know there that one thing that was
roused was the spirit of charity I think
that that's more pronounced now and
there may be a little bit more spirit of
service although not all that much but
one of the great disappointments to me
was that the President had the ability
to ask more of us the only thing he
asked was that we go shopping I mean if
there was ever a moment to ask us to
stop driving tanks around and start
driving more fuel-efficient vehicles he
that was that
the moment there are a lot of other
things that could have been done I think
that you know citizenship is a muscle
that we have let atrophy and we've lost
the habit of citizenship and I'm afraid
that we're gonna be taken by surprise
again next time it happens that shortens
my answer cuz that's pretty much where I
am I would just we were friends I just
said that's true I just had two things
there was a whole bunch of notion that
the age of this is this escape ISM was
over where you know we're no longer
going to amuse ourselves to death in the
words of one book about television now
how can we watch survivor when we've
just been through this well the
highest-rated program in the last few
weeks was the Tonya Harding Paula Jones
boxing match which I think pretty much
by the way I have a Clinton related
theory about Survivor you know the these
reality shows only became popular as he
was leaving the White House because he
was survivor you know every week you
wondered whether he was going to get
kicked off the island had to replace
that show somehow that's an interesting
point I had and I guess impeachment was
the ultimate that's right he didn't get
voted off the island interesting ok now
that leads to many other points that I'm
not even see spend I'm not going to talk
about that but the other four serious
point in the literally the hours of
after that horrible morning there were
all these comparisons to Pearl Harbor
and what struck me in the months after
was here was a difference by the time
Pearl Harbor happened we were already on
a war footing
we had peacetime draft we had a war
mobilization board and as soon as Pearl
Harbor happened everybody knew we were
in this together
you could not not be a citizen involved
in war because you're your husband
brother father son was was either
trading or fighting your food was
rationed your gasoline was rationed if
you were a woman at home you were likely
pulled out of the home into the
workplace possibly for the first time in
years if not your life you couldn't not
feel part of something bigger than
yourself and we're not there I mean
we're not there because nobody you say
we're not even being asked to you know
to see easy things yeah so I think
you're right I really do I also think
that outside of New York and to some
extent
this is not being seen as an attack on
America because it only happened once I
don't mean people are indifferent but
they see it the way we in New York might
see a huge hurricane or a flood it
didn't happen to the country it happened
there and I think that I think the lack
of change has been one of the things
that most surprised me so that's what I
think and now we're gonna turn to some
questions assuming I can read them what
was the biggest surprise for you while
covering the Clinton White House oh gee
I can't imagine what was second I want
to say oh I wasn't surprised by that one
by Lewinsky I just I mean you know after
after after I found out the timing of
the Paula Jones incident I knew that all
bets were off and that there was just no
controlling this guy sexually I mean
that Paula Jones happened three days
after Clinton made the first important
speech of his presidential campaign in
Cleveland on the same podium with all
the other candidates and he just blew
him away the national press was there
and everybody said wow who's this guy
and then three days later he was he was
asking one of his state troopers to
invite that lovely or not so lovely
woman up to you know meet him in his
hotel room so I wasn't surprised by that
case so what was your biggest surprise
if it wasn't done should I say the
Mexican bailout no I no no my biggest
surprise was how stupidly they went
about health insurance reform how how
utterly inept they were and how they
actually believe that you can win
something like that by one vote in the
Senate Daniel Patrick Moynihan our
wonderful senator from New York told
them throughout those kind of things win
7525 or they don't get through and and
they just didn't listen they you know
they never budged she never budged and I
think that we lost the chance I think
there was a real chance to have
universal coverage passed in 1994 and we
blew it in the discussion about war
veterans in the discussion of
people who the difference of generations
this question res doesn't McCain's
luster in that area bode very well for
him with the electorate I mean certainly
that was one of the reasons I well I
think certainly one reasons he did that
well was there was a guy who had a life
God knows before politics and who
probably had sacrificed as much as
anyone could and still live I would
extend that to all the Vietnam veterans
who were in the Congress the United
States Senate who by the way get
together privately across party lines
and find that they have a lot more in
common especially on national security
issues than they do with members of
their own respective parties the other
thing the McCain had going for him was
this and was something that was truly
extraordinary would when I saw it in in
New Hampshire new to saw it which was
this was a guy who was willing to I mean
he knew a lot about national security
and foreign policy knew nothing about
domestic policy and when people would
ask him a question from the audience or
make a point that he hadn't thought of
before he would say something like hmm
that's really interesting I haven't
thought of that before let me think
about that for a few days I'll get back
to you but tell me a little bit more
tell me and this was one of the most
unique political shows I think people
had ever seen and pretty soon he was
getting the largest crowds I have said
that I have done God saved me seven New
Hampshire primaries and these were the
largest and most economical crowds I
ever saw because people saw an honest
man the fact that so many people
particularly Vietnam veterans would put
on their uniforms or their jackets and
they'd bring their kids yeah to these
town meetings non-veterans the amazing
thing was that a lot of World War two
veterans came that way as well with
their grandchild it was really this was
this was an astonishing it really was an
amazing event and it was real it wasn't
ginned up by the press I don't think and
by the way speaking of getting back to
where we started
speaking of 2004 I wouldn't gainsay the
fact that John Kerry had Vietnam
experience at all I think that I think
that that is going to be a second
sniff acun advantage for him in the
coming presidential race especially
it'll give him the ability to talk about
military policy and even disagree with
Bush in a way that other Democrats
probably can't okay you heard it here
first why didn't the press talk more
about the accomplishments of the Clinton
presidency and why did the press allow
themselves to be seduced interesting
word into reporting mainly scandal
rather than the nation's business that
there was a second question different
handwriting why does the press spend so
much time on gossip announcements time
on the issues because bread and circuses
because you guys love to read about it
maybe not this particular audience but
no you know you look at you you look at
circulation figures and also cable news
ratings and you know people would much
rather speak about you know have here
all these Talking Heads who argue with
each other not people like Jeff but the
ones who yell at each other yelling
about late-night pizza delivery at the
White House then about the Earned Income
Tax Credit which most of them don't even
understand but beyond that I think that
something really terrible has happened
to the press it's been a big change
since you and I went into the business
skepticism is our natural state and it
should be always adhered to we've
slipped into cynicism and we've reached
the point where a cynical story a
negative story about a politician is
just about the only store you can sell
if you try and offer an editor a
positive story about a politician and it
runs you're accused of being in the tank
I think I've said to you before that you
know my goal in - in the year 2000 and I
covered that campaign was to be accused
of being in the tank as often as I
possibly could because I began to feel
that unless we say what these guys are
doing right we have no standing to say
that they are corrupt and awful and and
terrible and you know getting late night
pizza deliveries and so I succeeded with
george w bush i was accused of being in
the tank to him at one point bill
bradley at another
john mccain and another point and I am
very apologetic that I didn't get
accused of being in the tank to Al Gore
but he he's a really you know if he had
if he had really talked about the
environment a little bit more I would
have gone in the tank for him as well a
couple of questions that are linked
actually Are you disappointed in what
Clinton is doing in retirement and what
do you think his future is let's start
with the first one I mean we're not
talking about the last hours in the
White House of issuing those pardons I
don't which I'm really disappointed in I
mean that was outrageous I don't like
you anybody disgraceful it was
disgusting okay how about since you have
a problem with him going around
collecting hundred thousand dollar
elektra fees right in ten million dollar
books just generally kind of you know
shockingly the corn for the winner I I
think he has a perfect writer and earn a
living especially since he has never
earned a living before I mean you know
one point I bumped into him at something
or other and I said you probably learned
more in the last three months and you
didn't the rest of your life combined
and he said yeah you're right I am
disappointed in him in two ways one is
these stupid legacy meetings that he has
with people where he tries to get his
former staff to spin his legacy you
can't spin a legacy and anyway a legacy
ain't something that's going to happen
in the next two or three or five or ten
years it's gonna happen fifty
seventy-five years down the road and I
think that you know his place will go up
and down in that sense also the other
thing is that there were some plans that
he had that I thought were really
important and I think that September
eleventh kind of took the wind out of
them but I think he's still gonna go
ahead and do them I think he is really
interested in becoming very active on
the you know trying to raise funds to
combat AIDS in the third world and the
other thing that he really loves I mean
if you bump into him in your local
McDonald's ask Clinton about leapfrog
leapfrogging is the attempt to put
information age technology into the
poorest villages
and the poorest communities here that is
something man you ask him about that
he'll talk to you about that for two and
a half hours that's something that I
think he will ultimately be very much
involved in but before he has to do that
he has to write his memoir and I don't
know how on earth he's gonna do that
because this is a guy who you know can't
do anything less than four things at
once you know if he calls up you know
that he's doing crossword puzzle with
one hand he's reading something he's
watching television and in my know
talking to you as the fourth know that
would be a fifth and as we know sadly
it's not unprecedented that's wrong but
as you know and as I certainly know that
when you write a book that's all you do
you write the book you can't write and
be doing a crossword puzzle at the same
time or watching television and so I
think it's gonna be very very hard for
him to do this it's gonna be interesting
to see what comes out of it I always had
a and the only reason I had it was
somebody actually knows him quite well
years ago was speculated the one the one
thing and it's gonna seem like such a
weird idea and it's not exactly
practical anymore
the one thing absent the unpleasantness
of the last few years of his presidency
that might have been on the cards for
him and another way would have been the
Supreme Court is it's the only other
institution remotely where you have
power and he guy was 54 he had taught
constitutional law of the presidents at
you now when you when you're when you
have to give up your law license this
makes confirmation tricky well it's also
always the possibility that he'll become
a commentator on the Golf Channel right
it's a nice job but I mean we've only
had you know one other precedent to
finish his presidency while still a
relatively young man that was Theodore
Roosevelt and he made a mess out and he
did he made a real mess out of it he
destroyed his successor and he elected a
using an embittered Mandal the day he
died yeah actually the John Quincy Adams
is not a bad one one for Congress and
fight slavery that's right no that's the
best part of his life that's right I
mean it was a completely honorable thing
that John Quincy Adams did he became a
member of the House of Representatives
I'll bet a lot of people have asked you
this question but it's a good one why
couldn't Gore and Clinton work together
in the presidential campaign I guess of
2000 because Al Gore had III have the
since when did you become a psychologist
I think that that Al Gore was twisted
into a pretzel over his feelings about
Bill Clinton and his anger and also his
need to seem independent he and as a
result he seemed even more constricted
than usual and also kind of devious it
didn't seem to be who he was you know
the best line about what would one Al
Gore the presidency came from george w
bush's cousin john ellis who was working
at foxnews at the time and he said I
could never understand why Gore didn't
just turn to my cousin at one point in
those debates and say governor could
could you remind me what it is about
eight years of peace and prosperity you
don't like but he couldn't do that for
whatever reason but the other
explanation someone you and I know well
who was pretty important in the gore
campaign when I called this person in
the last week of the campaign and said
all right what what's why aren't you
unleashing Clinton and this person said
because every time Clinton gets into the
news our numbers go down I think that
that's probably true too but there is
someplace and been in between having him
come out on stage and dwarf you as he
would have and denying the fact that he
exists which was what Gore tried to and
also let me let me just say this because
all of these clintonites are running
this year and they have all have the
same problem and to my mind the only
answer to a problem like that and to any
other really big political problem is
comfort and a bit of confidence in a bit
of sense of humor and Al Gore never
conveyed comfort confidence and God
knows
humor speaking of speaking of which this
is a kind of a lied to that it's not
about all the clintonites running for
office and I don't think they all have
actually I think they all have the same
problem in fundamentally different ways
meaner skin bones problem in North
Carolina is not Andrew Cuomo's problem
in New York is not Robert Rice's problem
in Massachusetts they all have to deal
with it but it's it gets intriguing as
to how that does no erskine bowles
problem in North Carolina and Robert
Rice's problem in Massachusetts and
Janet Reno's problem in Florida is all
the same it was whatever gave you the
idea that you could run you could start
in politics at the top okay
why do you think there was so much
disloyalty among former staff advisers
such as Stephanopoulos DD Myers Dick
Morris Robert Reich after they left
office yeah you know it's interesting
that there was none of that
among Hillary staff members which always
spoke very well for her excuse me
but I think that that a big part of it
was the fact well let me say this I've
known the guy for 14 years and I've
never had an argument with him not that
I didn't try I tried a lot I tried
really hard sometimes but he would
always just kind of alight it and and
and figure out a way to tell you
something that was kind of what you
wanted to hear and make you kind of
agree that he was agreeing with you
when he actually wasn't you know they
would he was the exact opposite of Mario
Cuomo who would get angry at you even
when you didn't try to have an argument
with
and very creative within his use of
language - I must say but I think that
for all of these people at one point or
another Clinton looked them in the eye
and said you know I agree with you and
he was so good at it that you they
couldn't help but believe it and then
they were felt betrayed really seriously
betrayed when Clinton turned out not to
agree with them and I feel like doing
one of those Carnac the magnificent
because because this is one of those
questions that you and I love so much
it's a prediction question intro where
do you see Hillary Clinton five years
from now in the Senate being a kind of
policy grind you know I think that she
you know she takes the job very
seriously and does it in a very orderly
way and I don't know that her career
will go much beyond that you stake which
is money far by the way you state
Clinton did many good things but the
press didn't pick up on the on these
things
where were you let me
but let me say in my own defense that
with the exception of the hope
scholarships on many many of these
things because I understood the policies
and I cared about them I wrote about him
favorably especially in a domestic
policy side for the last six years of
his presidency I thought the first two
years of his presidency he had abandoned
the principles the philosophy which I
believe was a coherent philosophy that
he'd come to office with and had moved
left to the reactionary left I mean for
radical moderates like me moving either
left or right is moving backward and and
I thought he was a moderate to radical
moderate so I mean you could look it up
I did more boring policy pieces than you
could shake a stick at during the eight
years of the Clinton presidency and not
just about things that he did but about
programs out there that that reflected
the principles that he was he was in
favor of in Washington so I think that
if I were gonna fault myself it wouldn't
be in the domestic policy side it would
be in the foreign policy side where I
didn't pay enough attention to Osama bin
Laden where I didn't hold him in a more
it pays much attention in a critical
light to his dealings with the military
there are two there are two more
predictive questions do you think Colin
Powell will ever run for political
office no I don't think he will and I
think he's exhibit a in you know what I
was saying before that we've created so
poisonous an environment that a lot of
people who might normally run for office
don't want to there's also a bleaker
reason for this I think what he was
either considering running for president
or structuring the world's most
brilliant book tour in 1995 I think was
more the latter than the may well have
been Bob Woodward for what insisted
Powell never had any
and run for president but it was a hell
of way to sell books I think he may have
been musing about the idea a little more
than that
but the story that came out after he
declined was that at in the in the
discussions he was having with his
supporters all of the white advisors
said go for it and all of his black
advisors said don't they'll never let
you and that's a fairly pessimistic view
about the country but as some of them
said one of them said to him it only
takes one one nut and there was I
believe well unless I was misinformed
that part of the reason he did not or at
least what was on the table was a was a
concern about whether there wasn't
someone out there who was not going to
let the first black president be the
first black president well if they
weren't concerned about that then they
were crazy but I think that I think that
that was part of it but I think that
there were far more personal reasons I
think that's within within the family no
no that's also true I'm sure you know
Alma Powell once said to me we did the
first 30 years of the marriage his way
we're doing the next 30 years of the
marriage my way no that may have been
much simpler does Giuliani have any put
national political views anybody asking
us who's going to be the best picture
there's no question here you know it's
probably a Best Supporting Actor nominee
was Ian McKellen I think bro yeah take
that to the bank
but but in any Giuliani yeah I think so
I think so and it's something that we
did Giuliani lesson is something that we
should learn especially those of us in
the press who hated him because he was
obnoxious
I mean Giuliani was is will be obnoxious
was is and will was is was a really good
mayor and an excellent leader in a time
of trouble and I think that his
strongest point as a leader is the fact
that he didn't play to us bet he didn't
care about us at all that he just did
what he did
the
wine people always quote Winston
Churchill well not always I mean go days
without hearing it but politicians and
journalists left to quote Churchill
because he used a hell of a writer but
in one of his speeches and it actually
turns out it was in more but there's one
of his famous speeches and the opening
line on this radio address goes like
this
the news from France is very bad and the
reason why I read that I sort of fell
off my chair was imagine any American
politician particularly a president
someone in charge beginning to talk to
the American people saying I have really
bad news for you give me it
now if you remember Giuliani that for in
those first hours not only was he
literally running for his life that was
the first shot we saw him literally
running for his life but when he got up
in his first press conferences and he
was asked what do you think the death
toll is the first one the first things
he said was it would be more than any of
us can bear and one of the things I
think it's maybe the point you were
making I just wanted to put that
specific on it is one of the reasons why
he he struck so many people as exactly
what you wanted then was not later he
was the comforter and all that it was
the fact that he was prepared in this
moment of real crisis to level to just I
mean to just say what
it wasn't focus group there wasn't
Martin attested you know for me at this
point after 33 years of doing this I do
it partially out of habit they don't
have a 12-step program for political
junkies but but also for the moments
that they step outside themselves or
outside their advisors their marketers
and show us a little bit of who they are
Giuliani did that relentlessly and it
wasn't always a pretty picture but we
always knew that it was a real human
being
the other part about what about his and
I don't mean to use the word performance
because that but his what he did in
those first weeks many of you will
remember this
before September 11th he visited the
sister of a firefighter who had died in
in a fire just a regular old horrible
fire and she said to him you know I'm
getting married in a few weeks and my
father's dead and now my brother's did I
have no one to give me away and Giuliani
said half-laughs and they won't you know
maybe or she said to him why don't you
do it he said well maybe I will and it
was I think the weekend after September
11th on the front page of the tabloids
here is this picture of Giuliani in a
tux with a big smile on his face walking
this woman down the aisle at her wedding
and again I don't believe for a minute
anybody advisers said to him this will
be great you know be a great great way
to buck up the city it was just an
instinct that he would go to if he would
say the toughest truths and then he
would say but look life goes on and
demonstrated and I mean that's an
example what Joe was saying you know you
I don't think we would have known this
part about Giuliani had September 11th
never happened he left office to this
kind of mixed analysis good mayor jerk
which would have been it
another confounding politician I love
them you know but I might rather have
these confounding guys who have these
great strength and great weaknesses then
you know all these blow dried by the
rules' cookie cutter
listening to their political consultants
sort of people who bore the hell out of
us
okay and who also is very hard to lead
to be a leader when the essence of
gaining office is that you've been a
follower when you follow the dictates of
focus groups which is a perfect place to
put the this last question on the table
considering where we started who we've
been talking about a lot tell me in
public life who you regard even if it's
just potentially as leaders as people
who you look at regardless of ideology
and say yeah I listen I believe that's
somebody who who has the makings of what
I want to see
well in part you know that's a that's a
tough question to answer unless you see
someone in a position where they are
where they're doing it I mean for a few
days there it looked like you know that
that Bush was gonna be that person for
the week after September 11th I mean the
graciousness is a really important part
of that and no matter what else you
would say about george w bush he is a
gracious human being and that comes
through although he is way way way too
heavily scripted to be my taste and and
the fact that he would abandon basic
principles like free trade in order to
please the folks in the crucial states
of Pennsylvania West Virginia and Ohio
and steel imports okay so let me tell
like alright I'm gonna have to prod you
it's like getting the first olive out of
the jar I'm talking about people in
public life not who you say that's who I
want to be President
I'll give you a couple and you can tell
me if I'm right or wrong I think for
instance that Chuck Hagel of Nebraska
yeah is a guy whose Vietnam War veteran
okay interestingly enough who's as Curt
Anderson says in his novel it's a
wonderful phrase that his
signal-to-noise ratio is relatively high
yeah it's a great phrase I mean it's
it's a perfect way to put what you're
talking about
when I have had him on the show or
interviewed him I get the sense a lot
that I'm talking about guy who was
actually trying to give me something
approaching a real answer you know and
he'll say yeah yeah I'm sorry the White
House felt that hadded yeah I wish they
hadn't done that I can t remember the
issue at this point it strikes me as
somebody who that there's a real human
being so an advocate is now do you want
to try to put someone else on the table
or am I gonna have to do this again why
don't you keep going I you know there
are people in both parties that I that
I've seen that way try to name one well
I would I would I would name Barney
Frank as one okay certainly given me you
know he's a guy with a sense of humor no
doubt about that
he's the best debater I mean he's just
he's just wanted
and I would have you know I would have
put Bob Dole in that category too he was
not that good in front of an audience
but he was you know he was he was very
straight and great senator but I see the
the problem I have with the analysis of
you know he's great in small groups is
the political equivalent of she's got a
great personality
no but that's you know clear that about
a politician the great and small I mean
in in the legislature that's a really
impatient go I mean I remember seeing go
Dole campaigning in New Hampshire once
and a little girl asked him about acid
rain and his answer was that bills and
markup yeah I mean so let me try another
guy on you because before we run and
watch and you sell books and I go and
see if I'm right about what peace
monologue I would argue not argue I
would mention Bill Frist the senator
from Tennessee oh that's a good one
that's a very good one you're better at
this than I am
you're the cynic I'm sitting here with
people I admire and you're you're right
well I I admire a lot of different
people I mean but I but I don't know
that they are the that they're people
who I don't see as a leader now we don't
know that yet but I think Bill Frist who
is first of all what means I'm like
about he's a he's a he was before you
became senator a very prominent heart
surgeon he could have invented this
heart-lung transplant he's also one of
the smartest people about like
everything it's almost scary he's also
the only guy and only politician who can
actually swear to have saved lives
and who does and who does pro bono every
year he goes to Africa every year once
sometimes twice a year and just treats
people for a couple of weeks so that's
what I mean I mean you know I know the
journalists are thought of as you know
hopeless things but in that sense I'm
giving you one more chance here I've
given you two is there anyone like that
who you look at and say I kind of this
guy has or this girl this woman this
person this entity I don't want to you
know be limited has something there's a
spark someone said what about John
McCain I would certainly say John McCain
words I would I would say Max Cleland as
well I would say what was his name now
I'm get having a middle-aged moment the
guy who was the who was the same
Republican senator from Indiana and
coach Dan Coates one of the most
honorable men I've ever met in politics
you know people are honorable in ways
that you never expect let me throw out a
name here that is gonna make it some
hoots but when John Ashcroft was was up
for see this is a real shocker that they
know yes when John Ashcroft what I don't
even know if I can tell the story I'm
gonna tell it anyway when he was up for
confirmation his advisers wanted him to
go public with the fact that he spent a
lot of time helping young people at a
faith-based drug treatment center on
Capitol Hill and he refused to do it he
absolutely refused to do it he wouldn't
allow himself to be paid to have his
picture taken there he wouldn't allow
them to report that he did that because
he believed that that was another part
of his life and it was and it had
nothing to do with politics and to even
mention it would have been to manipulate
those young people he was dealing with
now to me that is an act of Honor I can
disagree with john ashcroft son till the
cows come home but i want to say that
you know it was it's always surprising
to me it always was surprise
to me that honor had wasn't surprising
to me that it that it that it didn't
have a party label on it but it was
surprising to me that some of the people
who you look at in politics and you said
he's a killer or she is really a wimp or
you know whatever quietly do and say and
live they walk the walk this is one of
the reasons why Joe Klein is one of our
best not better but best political
writers and if you want to start
unlocking the mystery that is Bill
Clinton the natural is one hell of a
place to start Joe thanks a lot
joke line is the author of primary
colors the running mate and woody
guthrie alive as latest as the natural
the misunderstood presidency of Bill
Clinton it's published by doubleday and
you can visit Doubleday com